on the hill today for the colorado
rockies will be the 27 year old
left-hander kyle freeland
has only faced freelance a couple of
times he's over two and ushrimski it's a
high drive to right it is out of here
and the giants are on the board it's one
nothing homerun number eight for us
just like this the offense is seeing and
feeling good thoughts again and we're
gonna get to see alex dickerson lines
this one into right field that's a base
hit
longoria is coming in and it's not in
time dickerson comes through and it's
two nothing
so here's joey bart who had three hits
in the game last night he had three
singles lines this one to right blackman
spins around it's over his head one run
is gonna score
dickerson stays at third
and
joey bart is gonna end up with a single
and the giants lead three nothing here's
daniel robertson who got a couple at
bats last night when one for two shoots
this one on the ground and a base hit
he's got an rbi and it's four nothing
and they're loaded for solano holter's
going to come out and have a word with
freeland this is your coors field first
inning pep talk
and he got him and that'll end the
inning hanson leading off the second
against logan webb uh oh this one's got
a chance get up get out
garrett hanson his third home run less
than 24 hours
number five on the season
you hit a home run you're
in the lineup the next day well if you
hit two home runs you're definitely
going to be there and then how about
three home runs
for garrett he gets to start on friday
night
so chi-chi's in there spilly's
describing and
i don't think anything's wrong with kyle
freeland this is a guess i think that
buddy just said man first inning long
not good second inning even though they
didn't score kind of more of the same so
little yazz
gaz junior junior
here's the payoff
and it's looped and he's got another
magic wand dude
and it's five to one a two strike two
out bat and the giants do indeed get
that run back
daniel robertson is two for two
and the walk and the giants will take it
they're going to give it to you
take it that's an rbi
trevor single to right
and that ball to the left field corner
two hops off the wall tapia
is gonna get a green light from stu cole
and tap's gonna score easily on the
double by story at six to two so here's
the situation the rockies are down by
four there's one out in the sixth
pillar and hampton back-to-back singles
but for a moment you may see matt kemp
with hilliard up against the lefty but i
think buddy wants to maybe hold kent
back for later in the ball game 3-2 to
hillyard
and that gets underneath the glove into
right field past flores one run is
scored pilar crosses hampshire to third
and it's six to three little break for
the rockies on that hot shot by hilliard
so josh fuentes up
this is to right field
it's caught out there and hampton will
come home on the sac fly stremski
returns it to the infield and it's a
two-run game six to four so now the time
run in the person of nolan at first base
nobody out
charlie who's been scuffling at the
plate try to narrow the gap here this
ball high in the air deep right field
got a chance
off the wall
story comes around nolan head to third
charlie blackman coming through it's a
one one-run game down 0-2 and he lifts
one to deep right field nobody out kevin
pillar to face his teammate from a year
ago
chatfield high school's tyler rogers
who's a right-handed specialist he's a a
side armor
and this ball is driven a deep left
center field kevin pilar comes through
charlie blackman around third the
rockies will take the lead pilar dig it
for third
that is a triple
rockies in front seven six
welcome to denver kevin pillar
that'll bring up hilliard and again this
is not a favorable matchup for tyler
rogers but he has to face him because
this is the third hitter
this should get it done deep left field
going back is dickerson it's over his
head it's out of the ballpark
opposite field two-run home run sam
hilliard and the rockies lead it nine to
six here's the 1-1
on the ground deep in the hole story
from his knees out at first base
what a play by trevor story as good as
it gets do it trev
well first you're thinking oh hopefully
you just get to it well he does more
than that he gets to it and then throws
from his knees i also like the other
play over at first base by josh
he uses the bag as leverage to get up on
top even higher one two he's got a ball
game over what a job by the rockies
cannot tell you
how needed this victory was
and it's their biggest come from behind
win of the year